quantos é que gostam de história
história uma coisa tão gostosa né
a história nos faz revisitar o passado
existem histórias que são boas histórias
que são ruins
histórias que nos lembram a vida
profissional à vida acadêmica aventuras
pois bem histórias que inspiram
histórias e hoje eu gostaria aqui de
compartilhar uma história com vocês uma
escola contra lama
a história de uma pessoa que dentro da
educação conseguiu compartilhar e
contribuir com a vida de alunos com a
sua própria vida com a vida de pessoas
que estavam em um aspecto de sofrimento
e agora está com a oportunidade de
transformar a vida de muitas outras
pessoas em dois estados brasileiros
essa história por fim da educação eu não
poderia deixar de ressaltar o grande
pensamento de paulo freire que dizia
educação não transforma o mundo muda as
pessoas e as pessoas mudam o mundo como
de fato são as pessoas que vão
contribuir e compartilhar para que o
mundo seja melhor pra que nós
vivenciamos novas aventuras novas
realidades novas expectativas mas isso
só é possível quando nós acreditarmos
que é possível
bom em toda a história ela começa como
era uma vez
só que essa história eu quero contar pra
vocês ela começa o ano de 1989 quando
esse casal aí projetou e no ano de 1990
nasceu essa criança
esse menino bonito aí que vocês estão
vendo que sou eu agora estou aqui hoje
para contar essa história pra vocês
esse casal de agricultores que moram lá
no interior do estado em nova venécia
projetou essa criança e essa criança
nasceu com sonhos como toda criança era
10 um sonhador e durante a sua infância
durante a sua adolescência sempre buscou
novas realidades
sempre buscou novas conquistas eu me
recordo bem que durante o período em que
estava na escola estudando a disciplina
de ciências química eu sempre fui muito
apaixonado por essas coisas mirabolantes
por aulas práticas experimentais
isso contribuiu muito para que em 2012
eu viesse me informar como professor de
química
essa experiência no ensino médio ensino
fundamental
ela foi tão primordial na minha vida é
importante que isso fez com que eu e
apaixonar se pela educação
durante meu colegiado a minha irmã que
também é professor de ciências
ela costumava a me colocar pra
desenvolver as aulas práticas porque era
um aluno muito interativo agitado dentro
da sala de aula e não deixava ninguém
estudar quando ela percebeu isso
ela então resolveu me colocar a partir
de agora você vai começar a instruir os
alunos das aulas práticas e todas as
vezes que tiveram na prática você vai
desenvolvê las
aquilo me fez se apaixonar cada vez mais
pelas ciências e em 2012 quando me
formei pela primeira vez em química e
ali estava com o meu diploma de
graduação e havia me tornado um
professor
no ano seguinte em 2013 eu ingressei
pela primeira vez em uma escola pública
eu fui professor essa foi a primeira
escola que eu cheguei
quando cheguei nessa escola
eu me deparei com uma realidade à qual
eu ainda não estava esperando porque
dentro de uma sala de aula dentro de uma
escola pública você encontra uma
educação tradicional e uma educação
contemporânea educação moderna
então o professor jovem que acaba de
chegar
os alunos eles depositam alguma
esperança uma expectativa muito grande
nesse professor mas ainda não tinha
experiência nenhuma como é que eu
poderia contribuir de uma forma melhor
dentro da sala de aula
pois bem através disso através dessa
percepção eu resolvi então agregar os
dois valores
trabalhar a educação tradicional e
trabalhar a educação moderna trabalhar a
educação contemporânea
era isso que os meus alunos estavam
buscando era isso que eles queriam
eu precisava de dar oportunidade para os
meus alunos naquele exato momento de se
expressarem de poderem dar a sua opinião
e junto comigo desenvolver um
aprendizado e ao mesmo tempo ensino
bom como era professor de química algum
professor que você vai dar aula onu ao
de química eu tenho certeza se eu
perguntar aqui pra todos né quantos
gostam de química
talvez a maioria pode se manifestar ou
talvez a maioria também pode não se
manifestar porque realmente é um
conteúdo tão complexo é algo tão é
exigente e quando você diz que o aluno
você vai dar aula de química o aluno já
logo coloca na mente dele duas
expectativas e duas em realidade
a expectativa seria que ele poderia
trabalhar diversas experimentações e a
realidade é que a roupa pode ser bem
chata pois bem só que antes de se criar
essa expectativa e realidade na mente do
aluno
a primeira coisa que vem são
questionamentos que eu tenho certeza que
muitos de vocês que estão aqui hoje
também fizeram no período que estava na
sala de aula porque estudar isso pra quê
estudar isso quando é que eu vou usar
isso na minha vida quem é que inventou
isso
são diversos questionamentos que os
alunos fizeram quando entrei na sala de
aula no ano de 2013
e esses questionamentos me permitiu
fazer e brilhar uma nova metodologia
diferenciada
eu preciso de transformar essa realidade
precisa de mudar esse conceito na vida
desses alunos
eles precisam de entender qual é a
essência da química com a importância de
estudar química porque aquilo que está
inserida em todo o contexto em todo
momento em todo instante
aquilo que está acontecendo neste exato
momento no meu processo de metabolismo
na produção de energia das minhas
células no processo de respiração e o
aluno precisava de entender e
compreender isso
essa é a essência da química bom essa é
a primeira expectativa que o aluno tem
experiências bombas
eu tenho certeza que talvez no meio de
todos aqui alguém deve ter perguntado
professor assim o professor
nós vamos fazer uma bomba para explodir
a escola
muitos alunos me impressionavam isso eu
dizia assim não porque se nós explodimos
a escola eu vou ficar sem trabalho e
você vai ficar sem sala de aula
então nós não vamos explodir a escola
bom pastor do seu tempo nem vem a
realidade ea realidade é fórmulas
geométricas cálculos químicos conceitos
ea principal da tabela periódica a
complexa informação mas a base e o
contexto geral da química bom quando
você começa a trabalhar essa realidade
o aluno então começa a entender que a
aula vai ficar chata e como você
transforma isso na vida do aluno será
que é possível
será que é possível fazer o aluno se
apaixonar por uma disciplina que é tão
complexa e contextualizada e vista por
muitos até atualmente né com um bicho de
sete cabeças
pois bem através dessa história eu quero
comprovar pra vocês que é possível
transformar isso na vida do aluno bom
durante o período então de 2013 quando
eu estava na sala de aula eu percebendo
isso na vida dos meus alunos eu falei
não eu vou transformar essa realidade do
aluno precisa entender qual é o
significado da química e aí eu comecei
então a trabalhar diversas didático
diferenciado na sala de aula
a primeira dela foi adaptar todo o meu
plano de ensino com músicas com paródias
para que os alunos pudessem agregar
aquilo ali de uma forma gostosa pra
aprender eu trabalhava numa comunidade
periférica e os alunos gostaram muito de
hip hop muito de rep
eles gostavam muito dessas música funk
principalmente e observando o tempo todo
durante as aulas eles gostavam de se
manifestar com esses hits eu resolvi
pegar o plano de ensino de química e já
de cara de início em 2013 tinha acabado
de chegar na escola errada tem todo meu
plano de ensino com música com paródias
as aulas eram maravilhosas gostosas
com isso eu comecei a construir sonhos
todos nós somos sonhadores né
ainda mais eu que tinha acabado de
entrar na escola na sala de aula
jovem ainda né e então tinha muitos
sonhos eu queria transformar essa
realidade eu queria modificar esse sonho
é real da educação
e ali então comecei a enfrentar algumas
barreiras porque quando você sonha com
algo quando você projeta um objetivo na
vida você enfrenta diversos obstáculos e
esses obstáculos
eles são críticas são invejas são
pessimismo na maioria das vezes até o
desânimo mas se você não desiste e
persiste até o final
você tem a possibilidade de alcançar
seus resultados e pela graça de deus no
final de 2013 eu concluir o ano e
participei de uma premiação no estado
essa premiação do estado da cdu me deu o
título de educador capixaba que é o cdu
boas práticas
conquistei o primeiro prémio na educação
aquilo para mim foi uma maravilha porque
eu tinha acabado de entrar na sala de
aula ainda não tinha essa experiência e
conseguir conquistar um prêmio pelo me
motivou a inter e sonhar novamente em
2014 eu fui para uma outra escola e nas
auto escolas alunos e eles não tinham
motivação muito grande é pra olhar para
a escola com um olhar diferenciado
então eu resolvi mudar isso dentro da
sala de aula dentro da escola com os
meus colegas e nos transformamos uma
escola que era uma das piores escolas do
município de nova veneza e era pior
mesmo é hoje uma das melhores escolas
com bons resultados com boas
qualificações e isso foi importante
conquistei um outro prêmio na educação o
prêmio inoves um prêmio de inovação e
sempre trabalhando com tecnologias
sempre trabalhando com músicas bom em
eu queria transformar essa realidade
eu queria fazer algo diferente porque eu
já estava enjoado daquela coisa monótona
aquela mesma coisa todos os anos e então
tive uma idéia é tão bom quando a gente
tem idéia né porque as idéias elas
transformam bom aconteceu um fato que
foi considerado uma grande tragédia no
país inteiro e se perguntar pra todos
aqui eu tenho certeza que todos se
recordam né
qual foi a maior tragédia aconteceu há
um ano atrás
no nosso país sim essa mesmo a tragédia
de mariana quando se rompeu diversas
milhões de rejeitos de minério
sobre a nossa bacia do rio doce que
corta o estado de minas gerais estado do
espírito santo
essa tragédia ela me permitiu abrir a
minha mente porque eu pudesse levar para
a sala de aula uma pesquisa científica
porque essa tragédia é envolveu
destruição de casas
ela envolveu desespero de pessoas
então eu observava que os alunos eles
questionavam muito isso dentro da sala
de aula mas eles não tinham muita
informação do que seria aquilo de como o
que aconteceu aquilo com a procedência
dessa tragédia e eu pergunto pra você
como uma escola pública pode agregar uma
grande tragédia ambiental no país com o
seu método de ensino melhor ainda como
alunos adolescentes de 13 e 14 anos de
uma escola pública do interior do estado
pode contribuir para informações para
metas que possam beneficiar pessoas
pois bem pessoal iniciamos uma pesquisa
científica e essa pesquisa científica
contribuiu com a melhoria do aprendizado
dos nossos alunos e com resultados para
a sociedade que eu vou mostrar pra vocês
através de um videozinho com fila junto
comigo
[Música]
o projeto surgiu na sala de aula a
partir de um questionamento envolvendo o
rompimento da barragem da samarco ea
contextualização da tabela periódica de
informações referente às barragens que
tem sempre essa marca e logo em seguida
permite que os alunos processos em
revistas jornais e realizar sua pesquisa
na sala de aula para que produzisse nos
cartazes e esses cartazes sejam
utilizados na comunidade para apresentar
a situação parece bem vindos também
realizamos coletas de amostras
entrevistas na comunidade levamos luís
para o laboratório da escola os alunos
então sentiu necessidade de aprofundar a
pesquisa diante desses elementos que
depois levar informações até essas
comunitários para que eles pudessem
realmente saber qual era o de metais que
estavam na água de onde se rompeu a
barragem como se deu a chegada do nosso
estado na própria comunidade de
residência
após cada análise era contextualizado de
acordo com os elementos químicos da
tabela periódica produzido portfólio uma
vez construção da tabela padrão para que
o aluno olhasse um outro olhar um olhar
mais atrativo mais dinâmico ea olhar ele
pudesse obter informações básicas
não é fácil compreender a tabela
periódica antes eu achava que a tabela
periódica era um bicho de sete cabeças
a partir daí se deu o segundo passo do
projeto que era tentarmos encontrar uma
solução ajudar a comunidade ribeirinha
de emergência que não tinha água
disponível nas suas residências do uso
do méxico e aí então desenvolvemos um
filtro de retenção médio eu esperava
através desse projeto os alunos
adquirisse um prego e básico
conhecimento da tabela periódica e ao
mesmo tempo que nós pudéssemos encontrar
função pudesse contribuir de forma
imediata e de forma individual a cada
comunitário afetado com algo além de
toda essa experiência na educação com o
professor o mais importante em
contribuir com uma didática diferente
diferenciada na sala de aula é saber que
eu também consegui transformar a vida
dos meus alunos
veja como no verão tabela periódica
antes eu achava tabela periódica era um
bicho de sete cabeças
isso é importante e eu desconstruir
aquele método é complicado aquele método
contextualiza da tabela periódica na
vida dos meus alunos e esse valor é
importante para o aprendizado para uma
educação de qualidade
só que o melhor ainda é quando você
agrega resultados à sociedade e vejo que
o projeto concluiu e agregou na vida das
pessoas
levamos soluções para pessoas que estão
sofrendo pessoas que estava desesperada
que estavam precisando de uma pensão que
era uma comunidade de regência os
ribeirinhos e esse projeto foi tão
importante que hoje ele está se
espalhando em todo o estado tanto de do
espírito santo quanto no estado de minas
gerais e as 3 milhões de pessoas que
foram afetadas pela grande tragédia
ambiental agora podem receber um filtro
em suas casas que possam filtrar as suas
águas que são as águas do rio doce e
poder reutilizar de forma doméstica para
suas plantações e assim sucessivamente
isso é importante eu acredito que tudo
isso agregou tantos valores e aí eu
entendo que a empatia ela está no ato de
educar e inovar transformar vidas
compartilhar experiências entre inspirem
compartilhem diferencie a cada dia com
tem novas histórias a partir de hoje
essa é a minha história a história dos
meus alunos ea história da comunidade
que estava sofrendo muito obrigado a
todos
[Aplausos]